in 2016
astronomers release astonishing evidence
of a missing ninth planet on the frozen
edges of our solar system
100 billion miles from the sign until
our telescopes find it we can only guess
what this mysterious planet 9 is like
but the first option is perhaps the most
surprising planet 9 could be made from
walk just like the earth but ten times
more massive a so-called Rockies super
earth planetary geologist Jamie
radabaugh
imagines Planet nine as a dramatic world
of fire and ice
these black mountains and lava flows
were created by leftover heat from the
Earth's formation spilling out onto the
surface planet dying born with so much
more enslaving rock should add even more
of this leftover heat trapped inside it
what we're talking about is a body
that's maybe ten times the mass of the
earth
I'd expect because it's so large that we
should have lots more internal heat and
so even though it's far away in the
solar system as far away from the Sun
it's still got lots of its own energy
touching down on the surface of planet 9
you'd find a world as inhospitable as
you could imagine billions of miles from
the Sun the surface is lit by little
more than the twinkle of distant stars
and the red glow of intense geological
activity on the surface we can imagine
if we're on a super rocky earth planet 9
we could have a landscape just like this
one there should be volcanoes erupting
all the time and the other thing we
should see is lots and lots of ice and
snow blanketing the landscape this is
because the atmosphere is so cold that
parts of it have condensed and settled
back down onto the surface you're going
to have volcanoes you're going to have
canyons you're going to plate tectonics
mountain building all of these processes
are still going to be going on out there
in what we normally would think of is
the frozen cold and dead world of the
outer solar system
as hot lava reaches the surface it
freezes suddenly in the cold of space
perhaps forming a weird volcanic glass
called obsidian another feature shared
with the sub-zero volcanoes of Iceland
ok let's put this whole thing together
we have we have a landscape that's kind
of dimly lit by starlight but maybe also
by the reddish glow from from erupting
lavas spreading across the landscape and
then behind you you have gases that are
changing immediately to snow and falling
as snow down to the surface and it would
just be a beautiful magical lansky
you